you
that was ready a gold one of everybody
to my dumb friends at all these comedy
you know from the Josh wolf show Chelsea
Lately a bunch of other [ __ ] Josh wolf
is here in the studio how are you man
good well it's like less excited than
any other time we were talking for the
best yeah why am I here that Tom Lewis
and Shawn we haven't been together all
of us in in a couple weeks so yeah I'm
I'm thrilled to be here for the reunion
stone this is like a huge reunion
tourists amazing yeah you guys are gonna
play your greatest hits a yeah yeah how
our numbers been the past few weeks Tom
really good really it's like okay Karen
I was getting excited that I had a
career Oh what's going on man thanks for
doing this ah thanks for having me down
man I appreciate it very much uh I has
your week been my what my week has been
what day is it Wednesday it doesn't
matter anymore right no my week has been
good I guess ah I had a really good time
at the Atlanta improv this weekend it
was one of those weekends where you're
like oh this is why I road and do you ha
midi that was the first headlining
weekend ever did two years ago and it
was a labor of love but my dad came to
one show and I was like does your dad
live in Atlanta no he he just had a show
there but I mean had a show he's a
writer so I was laying right plays a
playwright and it was the most awkward
we're telling you his dad's an award
winning player haha it was the most
awkward we were on the streets of Elena
mm-hmm and this is like a [ __ ] this
is one of the most times have been
ashamed and the most i've ever been
shamed for my dad he's seen me naked
hiding cocaine before as we were walking
down the street and we were walking down
the street it was true but uh and this
Duke this black dude came up and you
know and I just go like hey man I'm
sorry I don't have any change and he
goes dude I'm looking where the
convention center is and I notice he's
got a pulse he's got a full shoot
you look for homeless oh yeah I don't
was wayward better watch out man kicked
out of LA for that yeah I guess and
there was a Mikey just like I went to my
dad my dad and make eye contact him like
that was bad huh oh yeah I got I got a
couple question to me I got a couple
right one when you're naked high on
cocaine because he walked into a room
and yeah I was staying you know like I
was basically living with them and at
the time I was a real [ __ ] superstar
22 and I had what how I had cook Amy
this is even worse I don't ever talk
about this on podcast i think i did was
that I grabbed a little cocaine I had
hat laughs which was a bag because I
knew they were gonna take it away and I
shows that my mom and dad and they well
they walked into the room did they know
you were could dude that you did coke
yeah they knew had problems but uh they
walked in and I have a bit about I go
don't come in i'm masturbating right and
I'm like you know your wife's the sad
place of masturbations the safe option
yeah so I take the bag of coke and I
shove it up my ass and I wait and then
I've got home I guy got in my win my
room I did cocaine and read poetry and
then waited tell my parents went to bed
and I went down to the basement did the
rest of the cocaine and at five in the
morning my mom at a teaching job and I
could hear her [ __ ] getting ready and
I'm like this is a bottle and you were
naked I box John at that point okay so
cuz I didn't know they're coming home I
kid you know it wasn't her only thing
first of all your experience of doing
cocaine is way different than mine you
sure I had fun yeah yeah you say the
basement read poetry which isn't exactly
why people do code Sean have you ever
done coke no I never had Wow and Tom yes
really I don't know I thought you'd be a
definite no I did it I it was once but
it was like all night for 16 hours
before 16 hours you did it one time and
you never did it again nope never did it
again nobody likes a quitter man I know
I'm talks a lot if you like ask him he
knows a ton about comedy and I feel like
that you probably just cornered some
[ __ ] and talk about Mort Sahl
for it is that true is that kind of what
happened no I I think it we ended up
playing like pictionary for 12 of those
hours I mean you guys have the worst
cobra that's higher [ __ ] your coach
stories they're not reading poetry and
play Pictionary you I was a good one
those are the worst coke boys I have
ever heard of the opposite it was like
you're not Motley Crue here this
generous man a guy let me know what I
feel like an old man you you you guys
are not use generation of coke here's
the water oh man the guys waiting
waiting jumble is Hannah she also baked
a bundt cake yeah those are the two
worst coke stories I've ever heard Oh
congratulations my other question is
about your dad now yeah so your dad is
an award-winning writer yeah my daddy
should write for Cosby actually to uh oh
right crazy so right you're gonna leave
that will leave all those jokes alone
gray right Rob's X woman to step forward
so he be great if he had a [ __ ] stamp
of a Cosby sweater yeah if they have
everybody in the rape gang had like a
Cosby sweater tattoo and then somebody
be good I'm the rape gang probably not
something i should coin right oh that
sounds good um but do you ever go does
your ok mm-hmm couple things you out you
listen 10 things that you first [ __ ] you
so whatever like what about you I look
your uh your jokes what I like about
your jokes I told you this before is
that you're one of the few people where
I don't know where your jokes are going
oh thanks Jess it's the first time I've
ever been compliments on this pod get as
a comic like you can kind of trip to 20
minutes you'll figure it out but I can
start to figure out where somebody's
going with a joke yeah you does your dad
ever give you punch lines or critique
your writing he does not he critiques my
scripts but he's not funny so there's
really not like much you can do as far
as punch lines as far as anyone who's
held by punch line two
Nate fern old who's his comic he's given
me like three [ __ ] punch lines that
have been on TV I'll set up the premise
I have the middle part I'm like I just
need a tag yeah and he's great at it but
my dad can't I mean he just doesn't know
how to do he helps you to scripts oh
hell yeah he'll help us who he
understands structure and show like that
but he wrote for Cosby so he's not funny
he can be funny on its paper diamond
like a very sitcom way right but he's
not like he doesn't know how to do
stand-up or anything it's hardest thing
to write that's a difference you do you
write all yourself or do you have a guy
i do not have anybody help yeah yeah
because you know sometimes look I i I'm
I tell a lot of stories I go right right
and so a lot of times when you tell a
story the biggest punch lines when you
look at them on page don't even look
like a [ __ ] punch line no do you not
I mean it's oh that's the worst I've
been shot you've probably had that just
now with with dude you're half hour when
you do you have to write all this stuff
out for the Oh some reason we didn't
have to do it this time I don't know why
oh that means the was not gonna air just
so you know that just means they don't
think it's gonna hear that's why they
wouldn't that be [ __ ] up litter the
worse if somebody if you're special you
came on stage and then they just cut to
an old mugger chose they play the first
three minutes of mine just to [ __ ] with
me yeah yeah they set it up and they're
like we don't like this guy's voice it
sounds like I'll trouble it's so hard to
give [ __ ] when somebody's not in the
room cuz it feels like you're giving
[ __ ] to a ghost I'm getting you all the
finger right now you just can't see that
brick do you believe in ghosts do I
believe in ghosts I mean we're gonna
Michael shut in st. Germain interview by
Josh haha dude you're where you guys are
in Massachusetts and New York you're
figuring this out yeah [ __ ] christ
I've had to do the last two episodes on
my own well why don't can I talk about
my gut my dad was a jail guard at rising
your dad's dead Shawn get over it wait
your dad was a jail guard at Rikers yeah
come on does it she gets up this is the
saddest sequence ever Shawn just got
jealous that he wasn't being interviewed
on his own podcast but I want now
we're having to take time out of the day
of the but keep going keep going do you
have any do you have it did he ever tell
you any great stories he played Monopoly
with uh with Mark David Chapman the guy
who killed John Lennon oh my god that is
a great story yeah you did on that to
you let do you let him win yeah do you
let him win when he rose no no you get
bored walking let him win yes jumping
said I let him win why of course I let
it how have you how long have you done
this podcast you've never told that's a
great story yeah there's a great story
dad just doesn't listen it no I don't
think you have oh yeah definitely God
before he got stabbed once too you've
never told that story yesterday I don't
know I don't know the full day he
wouldn't really tell us much because he
didn't want us to get worried but he got
no I know he got stabbed once as I saw
the scar stabbed where and that's an
aside she's so that's like a did they
want to kill him yeah I guess they want
to get 20 years later I've had somebody
uh what this dad's dead oh we've been to
your dad dead jokes yeah I mean wait I
mean as long as we open well uh guys
jokes on Sean he's here right now I had
somebody I don't know if they tried to
kill me but I had somebody wait in the
parking lot for me after a show what did
you leave yeah yeah you know I what
reason was it a heckler that you went
after yeah and he was sitting here's the
thing he was where it was him a buddy
and there are two girls right yeah yeah
and this has happened to me a couple
times i would say in general um if i say
if there's couples there at my show it's
because the girls have talked their
boyfriends into coming to the show we're
all because of Chelsea which which means
they already hate me okay okay so that
is a safe bet they already hate me okay
beak and so when they say something at
during the show and I make fun of them
and then their girlfriend laughs at them
oh it's a bad situation it's about it so
one time in Nashville this happened in
Nashville there was a huge do
dude who he said something me and I said
something back and he said something to
me and when I said something back his
girlfriend actually stood up pointed and
laughed at him so much so when she sat
down he stood up and started to walk
towards the stage this was a big dude
and I was like you played xannies in
Nashville yeah no not Nashville I did it
in Chicago okay so they had they have
one door man who stands by the back door
and he's not actually a doorman it looks
like maybe he was one of the roadies for
the Allman Brothers right 70s ok so as
the guy starts to walk through the stage
I look to my left in the back corner the
dude who's the bouncer I see him
disappear behind the back his head was
looking at me and as I turned to look at
him his head disappears back behind a
corner and I told the guy go man you
gonna have to we have to sit down the
guy was like you making fun of me in
front of my girlfriend you'll be bored
booing hammer it they were like sit down
sit down as her [ __ ] yet he was a big
dude not like I'm about to get the [ __ ]
beat out of me onstage right right so my
first thing I think is I'm gonna take a
nice big swing at him with this
microphone you know you can whip it
around like right and then we'll see
what happens how you know you're not a
fighter yeah you just like fun to make a
powder puff girl can I say something
right now my record and fights is 4 and
6 i'm below 500 but so i know i'm gonna
get my ass kicked and then I here in a
huge Russian accent you know sit down
and three huge figure stand up they were
like sit down and I guess it out it was
three of the nashville predators three
of the National oh my god they they'd
come to the show I guess the coach had
brought a bunch from the show easy dude
football team hockey hockey they [ __ ]
saved my life so but the other time i
was in san antonio texas and basically
the same thing happened but they had
sent the girls home so they were waiting
for me the two guys are waiting for me
in the parking lot did they get did they
beat you up or no ah we just like I'm
sorry man no he I was walking out to the
car you know the the opener drives you
back to your hotel yeah yeah you know
who is a superstar you know he wasn't
gonna help ya
he was I just got 25 bucks for that set
yeah i'm probably i'm not getting
medical for this probably not getting
punchy face no the bouncer thank God he
was taking out the trash pointed at the
same exact time and walked over and gave
a is there a problem but I was about to
get my ass kicked Sean have you ever
gotten tighten up have I gotten beaten
up no I had a situation once were a
friend of mine poured a beer all over a
girl and he ran out of the bar and I
went a different direction and the guys
who were with the girl caught up to me
and I pretended like I didn't know him
but I don't like I was a separate dude
room and I did that thing where these
guys were calling their friends to come
over there's probably like eight of them
yeah they're like that sucks man your
friend left you here I'm I don't know I
don't know and then finally I could get
out of it i made a Hail Mary idea where
i can just freaked out I go listen I
don't [ __ ] know you want to find you
will fight right now is just [ __ ]
fight just [ __ ] fight and they went
oh don't worry about no no no it's fine
it's fine and they backed off because
that I just conveyed to them how much I
didn't know the guy and they're like and
they just let me leave but if I didn't
freak out at that moment and act weird
like that yeah they were they would have
kicked my ass they were better they were
calling their friend on their phone
texting their friends to come over at
you would see there's five of them than
there was two more there was two more
friends yeah you you should next time
you should just starts freaking out my
dad is dead my dad's dead my dad's an
award-winning playwright trembling voice
hey this is I forgot that let me bring
this up before I forget I was traveling
last week and the [ __ ] scariest thing
happened me I used to have a bunch of
night terrors which only Vietnam vets
and like fat asthmatics have and fit and
I I had which one of you Oh ladder but I
warmer and the ladder III anyway I had
this horrible dream where I was like
stuck in a serial killers like dungeon
and I couldn't get out and there was
like bricks of the wall I woke up and I
was staying at my openers place and I
was in their guest room closet tarek
like throwing tearing up photo albums of
one of the guys
live their family ah and then the TV was
kicked over I had I get in the middle
night I was trying to escape their
through the room it was [ __ ] crazy
first of all yeah what gig makes you
stay at the openers that's what I take
away from that story I was like hey this
is it this was definitely a run I put
together you know yeah um so I was
staying there and yeah it was like it
was crazy I almost understood cuz
there's that story of the guy who
murdered his wife and asleep and I'm
like maybe that's true well you know I
listen not to get too yeah uh too
serious but you know they're dudes that
wake up they that sounds like a little
PTSD thing they wake up and they're
strangling the produce Josh if I found
out that I was molested at some point
yeah it wouldn't make all the sense you
know let me explain the beard I'm just
dude I'm looking for it yeah because the
beer me I'm trying to hide yeah I just
have no chin but I I would love to find
out what that is how long you been
bearding that a couple years and what's
the game plan Sean's got a beer too is
it a struggle extreme is yours ah it is
not as extrusions now yes I don't know I
just trim mine actually Sean just looks
like a Food Network host Alice get bail
mammoth at work if he was here yeah let
me keep doing visual jokes for
somebody's country and for someone who's
never seen before in person wait I'm
gonna post this picture so we all right
um a wig so we aren what's what's going
on we have errand is our time are you
all right did you you guys just had a
moment Oh Aaron hey I keep touching this
thing by accident okay he is Gavin him
not us damn crazy it's me oh hey Tom
it's me I know it's not you are you
gonna post a pic on am an audio podcast
I'm gonna yeah is that what's happening
right now know what you looking for a
picture on a podcast this I'm sorry I'm
sorry I just want to explain that here's
my question is that true I is that truth
is that story about you shooting your
pants when you first met your wife true
true totally true true well I mean look
you add punch lines in there right right
exactly but true yeah and she's stayed
with you after them yeah uh
sing right like she would stay with me
sugar wasn't a break period like a month
period where she's like let me think
about this no I you know I think I think
she enjoyed the candor Sean have you
ever [ __ ] yourself in front of your wife
no man I am DD's governor's up front of
a girl that I liked in high school thank
you you what I sure myself in front of a
girl that I liked in high school I got a
huge crush on but we've all [ __ ]
ourselves once or twice right oh yeah
what's that now what ya was yours are
you or an hour when you say the coke
story are you oh yeah no I don't do it
anymore um but I I've definitely ship
mice have I should myself i remember in
ireland i was well as the same thing in
your talk about your stories oh yeah
quickly you have to realize when you say
[ __ ] yourself there's two different
meanings of [ __ ] you yeah we're angry
well think of it as just [ __ ] a
little bit and like and just barely
making it to the bathroom just a little
bit your pants the other thing is you
full-on take a [ __ ] and you're you was
that a full-on her a little bit hey well
here's i was a full-on when I was nice
cool here's what I would say I i think
that's that's nice to differentiate but
i think as soon as you have [ __ ] in your
pants you [ __ ] yourself i don't know i
mean like i do think if it's coming out
of your boxers though I mean that's a
whole new it's a different world but uh
smell is still gonna be its business the
thing about [ __ ] is you can have a tiny
nugget of [ __ ] or the biggest pile of
[ __ ] and it still just smells like [ __ ]
register you know the mean like that
doesn't oh god one of them just makes
you feel so much worse yeah a mine was a
you're both armies and then it my ass
hole opened up enough lock the at you
know when you sneeze right yeah so that
that pressure hey your ass hole opens up
for that long and shuts you clunch it
right away so however much a sneeze full
of [ __ ] is that's a new saying that's
gonna be the next number it's gonna be
the name of my next book yeah four
sneeze full of [ __ ] it's just you want
to cover in a white suit with like no
socks
got one of those advice oh yeah nobody's
ever said a sneeze full of show now
we've just coined a new term yeah that's
the grossest to remember and and you've
been with a Roy 20 years in Aaron I have
been with my wife we been married for 11
years and we've been together for like
my son is 18 to 14 years 14 years so
we've been together for 14 years for
years you guys work together well I know
we've been married for 11 and we've been
together for 14 but your son's 1800
that's it from another woman so yeah
you've done your research on me I see
literally got three I've got three
things on here it's like it's like a
person with Down syndrome grocery list I
don't say here's the reason here's the a
long time ago I met a woman and she had
two kids already we had a kid together
um the kid together is the one you met
yeah she ooh I ended up kicking her out
but I kept all three kids so I kept her
two kids and my kid Jesus so um I was a
single dad living in Hollywood in an
apartment for years we all got in one
room and so I God yeah my dad you know
he might and I'm from the Northeast to
my dad walked into our my apartment once
you know my apartment was a bed and then
two sleeping bags and a crib and there
was toys all over the oh my god and my
dad walked in and he goes mmm you know
you're pretty close to be in Puerto
Rican i'm going back to you and that was
hit and if you hadn't made it that would
be you you have to now you have the
pursuit of happiness story but if you
didn't you would have liked the sad like
like Angela's Ashes story yeah yeah yeah
there's like two like you're like in
this book i'm either coming across the
greatest dad of the worst stab it buzzes
over it's both it's both look great I
made some horrible parenting decisions
early on because it's not what's the
dumbest a parenting decision you made Oh
dumbest yeah that's a really tough call
i would tell you this because i usually
the parenting decisions i made early
we're good for two of them and bad for
one you ever you learn that you can't
parent all your kids the same way right
um I would say the may be the most
dangerous
thing you know we used to have a lot of
fun right my kids you know I didn't have
any money yeah um so my favorite game
for them is that we would i would put
them in the trunk of the car and they
like to roll around i would drive around
with that way i would you drive around
with it with the trucker's car now
listen I never drove around like on the
city streets right it was like empty
parking lots and every now and then
they'd want to go up a hill so we'd have
to go up we do you know where you know
those help near Runyon Canyon oh you did
in LA yeah oh this is was dangerous
[ __ ] thing ever well the parking lots
were empty but the Runyon Canyon was a
dumb one but they want they like the
feeling to gov being going up a hill so
we'd go up like seven miles an hour and
I'd stopped and started so i'm not sure
that was it was called Elizabeth Smart
the ride but here's what here's what I
had to stop my the kids been loved it
they didn't know any better and they
were young and they thought it was just
part of growing up so one time we were
in the parking lot at ralphs and I was
putting the groceries in yeah and as a
police officer was walking by my
daughter goes make sure you leave room
for us in there I can't wait to ride
around in the trunk and I was like oh
hello yeah who was your parenting
teacher Andrea yay yeah good reference I
mean follow everyone's doing what
everyone Jubal right now it would have
been really it wasn't really good but
the way you set it up was like was like
I can't you guys talk over me I can't
hear you you're the best part of the way
you said that was that that was gonna
have the biggest payout involved yeah
you know who was your pet Andrea Yates
you couldn't see the the Carson golf
swing
great usually I'm the one getting [ __ ]
on an episode I really like this hookups
I'm like the cool one on this episode no
I gotta go where you have to go what do
you have to do right there what is that
what it what do you have you not
finished that episode of bones yet Shawn
never seen an epic seen a minute I said
that too late the injury a tree yeah
that was bad to have you seen a minute
of that i have seen exactly 10 minutes
probably over 10 years of that show cuz
it's been on their bones yeah very
successful oh I watched the episodes in
a day I've never seen one minute of that
show David brands or whatever the [ __ ]
his name but that's like it yeah what's
that that mark harmon show NCIS and
that's not everyone I love I spies that
show and I've never watched it but
that's the thing like not like Mark
Harmon I like Mark Harmon but those
shows are so [ __ ] I don't know if you
some reason you know why because it
takes to place on one order sometimes
yeah I'm on your sickness so so I get
mad my god you live the life of a
widower yeah you're like my man right
there it's in no way anyone order I am
glad the CSI New Orleans didn't take off
I mean I like Scott Bakula but those
posters were just tough you saw those
like on yes yeah well the posters Roy
instead of like normal NCIS or it looked
like cool and they're gonna it was like
them like it's at NCIS New Orleans
you've seen the posters and they were
all i kin like open purple shirts with
beads around it was like like they tried
to make it like it was a carnival cruise
even though it was about probably the
rape and murder of somebody which is
just like a carnival cruises pres like
every 48 hours whatever yeah I will tell
you how I went out for CSI cyber which
is actually a pretty popular show I went
out for like the fat computer guy to be
in it like I Bob you didn't go out for
the romantic romantically with you
within
equestrians what did I know I know that
yeah but believe we can go up for a
holistic swimmer why's he wore down the
best buy can I ask you a question how
many how long did you practice your
waddle at your house well he's been
living that waddle for about 36 years Oh
bottle point yet damn you're closer to
Waddle point that I no no we weigh the
same and I've got like three inches on
you know three inches on me yeah well
what's your what's your what's your what
are you 58 58 and a half yeah you know
when you're when you're below 59 you add
that half and 5 10 and a ham I have like
two inches on you yeah that's not three
inches jacket all right well I don't
know I don't know what's going on with
you you've had a really good couple
months so I think we're going on with
you Sean I don't know why you're getting
annoyed Sean what's he had some good
stuff happy just did his record with
comedy central it's awesome just did a
special you know I really don't like the
fact that I'm not there right now to
defend myself properly I like it's like
it's like like when I'm talking about my
kid when he's crying in the corner like
he had a great day and what's going on
he usually doesn't act like is really
sorry I had a friend of mine recently
and he I don't have any young kids he's
got a young kid so he a lot of my
friends they started so much eating my
youngest is 18 right yeah so all my
friends are starting kind of now and I
started way earlier so they call me with
questions about their kids so my buddy
calls me he goes hey I got a question
for you I'm sure you ran into this when
Jacob was younger I go go ahead he goes
you know when we Tommy yeah hey because
when we put Tommy in the room he you
know for by himself for a loan play time
whenever we walk back in there there's
feces smeared on the wall he goes what
did you do when Jacob did that I go I've
never [ __ ] heard of that has he
killed as he killed your dad me feces
rug on the wall videos that's not a
normal I go
oh yeah he's like yeah that's an inside
voice yeah I he was like thats not
normally go well it wasn't normal in my
house I go how long how many times he
done it he goes I don't know like 30 i
go 30 oh my god I'm safe his kid to the
best oh yeah baby that's just what it is
he just hasn't like oh you gotta show
Mady use it all right I know I was like
listen I would I would Google that
because that sounds like he will be
killing small animals now that's a rough
one I mean have you seen that show I
that movie we need to talk about kevin
now it's pretty good if you see it you
haven't you Tom or Sean have you seen it
I won't watch any more movies dan tells
me because he told me to watch dear
zachary did you watch that oh that's a
rough one oh my god what's that I'm
using to the dargah shits about of this
basically this is the premise and it
gets even like sadder but it's uh this
cut of this this guy meets this girl um
Hebrew 80 he's a little older him he
breaks up with her buddy gets her
pregnant she ends up murdering him even
though it's not proven yet and it's
documentary it's about her and that
guy's parents raising the kid together
and them knowing that she murdered him
but they don't want a little custody of
the kid or anything to happen the kid
took them sharing joint custody like
Mary yeah during this trial it's [ __ ]
I'd I want to see them yeah it's on
netflix still yeah it is it's like that
the best made documentary ever but the
story is like that's amazing what the
[ __ ] I love stories I gonna ruin your
day what and so what and then then you
said there's something about Kevin what
is that there's other by Kevin that's
about tildes it still to swim shoes
awesome in him and it's about her kid
who is basically showing all the signs
of school shooter and like in this early
not a documentary this is just her and
john c reilly or the parents and exact
can do anything he's great I saw him on
we're all the way with philip seymour
hoffman he also tours it with a little
banjo band it's always annoying isn't
like when somebody can do like he when
we i did a theater in fargo yeah and I
look on the wall and there was like john
c reilly bandana
wow it's like what was it Sean whose dog
stars that keanu reeves or Russell Crowe
yeah that's that's Keanu Reeves but like
also 30 second to mars is uh is Jerry
Lee ok guys so annoying huh why is he so
good-looking he's good looking great
actor though yeah he's a good actor I
totally reason I thought he was gonna be
that him in Dallas buyers club turned me
around he was good although there's a
lot of complaints about like that he was
like almost men strolling it up a little
bit come on come on yeah I mean that's
it I think that's a choice he made right
i think that he it's also there's people
who act like that dude and that guy that
character would travel I just had a I
just had a vision of you is the
spokesperson for GLAAD still talking
like that yes come on you guys are
different come on admit it I mean it's
not a terrible then you should put it
down you should record on as higher till
I get kids out of the closet were
confused come on out of here everybody
knows you're a queer he's good though I
you know movie I liked is that panic
room movie remember that what he
fostered yet Forest Whitaker really yeah
I mean oh that's right at you it oh you
know it's great anybody sees this the
gift looking great movie oh yeah [ __ ]
that's the first positive thing Mike
Lawrence is set on facebook in the
[ __ ] three years oh did he say was
great he got his well go see go see the
gift what is not from your childhood it
won't disappoint you uh-oh its threat to
thriller that joel edgerton you know he
was in um he's in a bit of a bunch of
movies he's great and he just is his
first in writing directly it's actually
him and jason bateman jason bateman's
great in it and it's like oh that's out
now yes i get dark yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like adult scary like that's how I
describe Mike oh this [ __ ] can happen
let me ask you a question yeah are you
or you would you like to see Jason
Bateman or Paul Rudd pull it back a
little bit i just i know i like both of
them but i say that like I'm like guys
hired me uh but uh you know I Paul rathi
i would i would say what's yon I said
answer the question [ __ ]
[ __ ] come out of the closet well
here's the thing i like Paul I love both
those guys yeah I you know that it I
think oversaturation has hurt there well
it's what happens in Hollywood and you
know that year when Whitney Cummings had
like three show yeah you know and it's
just like and they're everybody it's
like they got that because they're good
but you you know like the entertainment
industry panics and Rick all right we're
all gonna get in on yeah yeah and it
backfires yeah because i love do Paul
Rudd makes me laugh and so does jason
bateman but I would they would make me
laugh more and again they are in every
movie they're in there like I would see
that then the more I see it I'm like
well now that they're just I wish they
weren't in as much yeah well yeah it's
it's tough Sean you agree with that
right yeah no I totally agree with that
hundred percent when you get too much of
me like all right we get it yeah you
know if you're gonna go clueless cast
members why isn't stacey dash done more
yeah right by the way that's my latest
blog yeah I was talking about that it's
really weird that you would bring that
up but yet well there's an article that
came out that apparently like her friend
recorded or saying like like she doesn't
even believe half this [ __ ] she's like
but you know what if you're a Republican
you can stay you could stay if you're a
woman Republican you can [ __ ] stay
more relevant until you're like 60 like
Ann Coulter and you can't do that if
you're a liberal hot chicken so true Oh
person yeah well that's it I don't know
it you do some you know like there's
some evidence to that I guess I mean
gesso because maybe there aren't rent a
van susteren Jesus you know I think her
an ann coulter are the same person
hahaha i'm not sure if greta van
susteren is like ted danson analytic
yeah she's a rough one I actually I can
see the strings behind her with people
moving it like it is bizarre use Michael
circus in the next room Andy Serkis fine
where do you fall that funny that would
have been good yeah where do you guys
fall on Trump I mean uh well Sean only
answer this first cuz you know I'm
consciousness that's easy I think why my
thing is I I'm starting to think it's a
[ __ ] practical joke dude hi I just
luck do you do a bit about it yet good
love doing evil joke uh cuz they think
that
because he went to the clinton's wedding
and he's like isn't he like he's
pro-life and he's like pro game Aron
yeah but he's saying that he's pro now
he's saying he's pro he's pretty boy
sprout you saying you used to be
pro-choice now he's saying he's pro-life
yeah I've been doing a bit about it
where it's like it's almost like two
frat guys are made a bet and they're
just like go out there say the [ __ ]
craziest [ __ ] and it's working well you
know greatest comic who ever lived if he
pulls this off and it's a joke well with
Sacha Baron Cohen at the end of it it's
Carol if he rips off his mask like did
we do what I do show what I think here's
the thing I think he's batshit crazy but
I also think it's kind of funny how he's
actually like how their people are
reacting to them like it's a real thing
I am I agree here's the thing like on
one hand I actually think it's good
because that you look at the viewership
yeah right it got a bunch of people who
have never been interested in politics
it leads to watch do you I mean and i
always think that's good but I it scares
the [ __ ] out of me that there are
millions of people in this country who
have just decided to vote for somebody
because he speaks his mind well yeah
what that does not qualify you to be
predito the most powerful person in the
[ __ ] world so that's what scares the
[ __ ] out of me a little bit yeah also
scary that there's no safeguards in
place that can make it met this guy does
it become president oh there will be a
safeguard it'll be called call the
public of assassination no there's no
way JP Morgan will let that guy there's
no way yeah no way there's no something
will happen they will take him in a room
in the back hey this has been really fun
but uh it's like that bill hicks joke
they'll show they'll be like this is uh
over right now yeah this is over right
now um and Trump's not an idiot you know
he's gonna understand at some point I I
also think that in his heart of hearts
he doesn't want to be President because
if he's present run his businesses but
what he's doing right now this is the
thing that I don't think people
understand I don't think in all honesty
as much of a narcissist as he is that he
thought I'd be winning I'd be ahead of
impulse what he thought and I am what I
thought too was it would
just reintroduce him to America he had
disappeared a little bit for his brand
for who he is he needs to be out in
front he needs that [ __ ] for his
business so now he's alienated people
who didn't like him anyways but now the
people that did like him and he's got
new fans are gonna help his business
that's about his speaking engagements
dude he's gonna make it's gonna be crazy
to be crazy right yes and with that guy
to he's always wide about how much money
he has yes so it's like wow you never I
mean even now they're saying he's as
assets are worth like you know a regular
of my assets are worth nine billion or
11 billion but um I don't know but
here's I ok there's a wire you know what
I do love about him is that he's not
scripted like it goes up there and he
just talks there's no prompter
unfortunately he would make yet he would
make the worst president brought he's
not above peppers to be [ __ ] awful it
would be an embarrassment to America
every right dude I'm not even kidding
like I've never I've never been one to
think if this guy wins i'm gonna move
like a George Bush was president again
I'm gonna move I never thought that with
this guy was president I would really
honestly consider moving I think Ted
Cruz who where I don't know he's like
penguin I would go to Connecticut cuz i
am Douglas I mean I think Ted Cruz would
be worse that guy that guy's dad
believes i was i did this game now her
taxes dad bullet yeah his dad believes
that the Second Coming is going to be
during his lifetime and Ted Cruz is
gonna be the person I usher us into that
Ted Cruz looks like a Simpsons character
oh it's insane he's the most unlikable
[ __ ] person I've ever seen yeah and
even Republicans are just like yeah well
I know I don't think we can go with this
guy I did you watch the debate I did and
I Ted Cruz makes Rick Santorum look like
the [ __ ] fun yes yeah it's crazy the
most unlikable guy I think I've ever
seen in my entire life I agree amber on
a stage ever and I've been through
hundreds of open mics he is without a
doubt the most unlikable I'm gonna tell
you like out of that I and I my politics
I fall somewhere in the mecca yeah like
I think most of
people do right i think if you agree
with one side a hundred percent that's
called a cult and you probably shouldn't
agree with one person under percent so i
fall somewhere in the middle like most
people but that grew it was like an
extended SNL sketch yeah wasn't it yeah
all three people I was like what the
[ __ ] are we watching here decision
because that will be the 10 minute SNL
skit that opens the trip it should be
because it was the most ridiculous thing
I've ever seen and then I know people
like where we love ben Carson it's the
same thing look he's agreed very soaring
and a bird looking very smart guy
neurosurgeon you know that you know what
qualifies him to be President [ __ ]
nothing but those guys don't know
surgeon that didn't he talk about his
foreign policy was based on what God
said the Bible or something we're ben
Carson soda talking about God like but
like his political policy hey I mean I
think that's just a go to ever it's like
what about when when they ask a
politician what his favorite book is and
they're like the Bible and I'm like
really I'm said that last night did you
hear him it's a it's a bit it's gotta be
a a bit it's gotta be a bit at this
patata me there's no way it was so when
he said it last night you didn't watch a
speech last night I didn't want I know I
didn't watch that one somebody said he
goes you know he was talking on his book
anyone have the art of a deal in here
the art of a deal it's my second
favorite book you know my first layer
book is the bible honey gave a thumbs-up
like I saw that coming and it's not
believable I didn't know he's gotta be a
joke you know if he is elected president
I don't think he's gonna be as bad as
somebody like a ted cruz or even a
george w bush I just think he's gonna be
the most corrupt president like he's
just like all his policy initiatives are
gonna be a first step of securing a deal
with Iran building a trump tower you
know you know he said he didn't say last
night he said you know the problem with
politics is that you know the the
lobbyists have their hands in their
pockets right I give you a million
dollars you've gotta do what I want you
to do he said how do I know that because
I've given people a million dollars and
then called in favors before so he like
lifted the [ __ ] bail off yeah yeah it
was good but yeah I was like sense why
he won't be President by the way it's
cuz that they're not gonna let that
happen cuz anyone who thinks like I'm
not gonna go into conspiracy theories
guys I've done it before are you compare
yeah I wouldn't say that but I'm open to
possibilities but I'm just saying like
I'm just saying the rothschilds
JPMorgan's they're not gonna [ __ ] let
that happen it's just not gonna happen
this guy there are bigger there are much
more powerful unseen people that are
running this country who have no desire
to run for prez one hundred percent so
they're not gonna let that out of course
why do you think they were knows that
also proves that he's not one of the
elite that he's actually no drum was not
one of Trump isn't here's why they want
would happen Trump one of the thing that
the Barras is trumped the most if you
bring it up to him is that he was just
denied entry it was a couple years ago
into the most exclusive golf club in the
world uh because they don't consider him
one of the guys really oh I think that
that's why he won't like we'll get a
[ __ ] Rupert Murdoch he hates him like
he's he's new money he's not Hearst
money he's new money well you know
what's funny too is it is to hear his
supporters you know talk about him a
self-made man he was given 40 million
dollars 40 million dollar and has
bankrupt you know he's his fico score is
in the lower ten percent yeah the
country cuz he's been bankrupt so many
times so I mean I know look he's as far
as a pot I like watching him talk yeah
more and if we learn anything from you
know look your sound bites in today's
generation yeah I want to get good one
that's what's gonna get you elected Oh
far as the soundbite nobody Jeb Bush is
the most boring i would i would is the
most boring person I've ever heard talk
oh he's he's vice presidential he's not
presidential even though he's like never
Secretary of State ish yeah he's the
he's probably he's the smartest guy
that's on that stage yeah but that
doesn't mean it doesn't mean anything
haven't we learned that smarts don't
mean any matter I mean if you remember
the McCain campaign that failed the one
sound bite that made him look good is
when they're like how would you get a UH
esambattu odd knees like I'd follow him
to the gates of hell yeah and everyone
kept prayer that over which is like the
craziest clint eastwood [ __ ] you
follow the gates of hell no you wouldn't
shut up [ __ ] old we
no uh-uh i think john mccain could still
kick your ass John McCain I think I came
you think so sure I mean know what his
IQ no it's all better reach as a fighter
yeah that guy doesn't have much of a
reach I think you know pain threshold is
probably through the roof maybe I don't
know guys think about the whole Bernie
Sanders thing with the black lives
matter protesters I don't I got in
trouble of that on facebook I think that
it was I mean I think it was [ __ ]
gross with those women did I think it
was like really shitty yeah [ __ ]
think they picked out the wrong guy
picked the wrong well then it's because
he doesn't like have he'll let them go
up because he's the most burger and now
he's having an amazing like let us speak
he's like okay it was just announced
last nitee he's having them now he's
having a black life matters uh the
movement speak before his speeches like
so it's like [ __ ] what I just but why
what why I I have no idea and I why I
mean I you know I think there's a [ __ ]
I think he's concerned about I mean I'm
concerned about police brutality
everybody's concerned by police / dad
well hacen is a big part of his platform
also she was one of those women was a
sarah palin supporter what yeah yeah
okay what yeah neither of them were
actual black lives matter they weren't
mmm they're a spin-off they have nothing
to do with wise man and well that's and
that's another thing where it's like it
wasn't the movement which it makes that
movement which is a great awesome
movement that did all this like really
progressive protests in New York and
makes them look like [ __ ] because they
have nothing to do it it's almost like
in the 60s or 70s when [ __ ] cops or
FBI agents who dresses like hippies and
then start riots that was a scam I don't
know if it's a scam but it's al it
doesn't sound great so those two women
were not part of the movement but they
pretended like they were part of the
movement or we just assumed they were
part of the movement we just assumed cuz
they were black and they were wearing
black flat matters to their enjoyment
there were same black lives matter huh
yeah yeah they were saying a bunch of
that I mean I think what it brought up
is is the appalling lack of security at
Bernie Sanders events yeah you could
just go and then get up on stage
right next to him I mean those brains
out dan you should do it next time but
just do it tight five yeah just
different I was so now black lives
matter and then dan st. remains going to
five and then I'm gonna speak oh my God
he's car Caitlyn Jenner what do you call
her that'll be great of everything so
every every every Bernie Sanders speech
was a three man show black lives matter
opens new middle and then he closes yeah
and then closing out Yakov shamira yeah
bring back the Blackhawks better yeah
Bernie Sanders poll numbers like
reaching a whole new low did you hear
his folk album that's the [ __ ]
greatest thing I've ever heard what do
you mean 40 years ago he was like a folk
singer or something or three years ago
to your at least a like a folk like
reggae to have you heard it Aaron you
really a fight it's like it's so bad
it's just him like you know how Leonard
Woody Allen getting some yeah he's like
I was walking down the street it's like
that I just have to go to have to listen
to it it's like you know the new like
true detective season 2 theme song where
it was it's Leonard oh I love winter
comb but that steam fog sucks and it's
just him speaking over like that mind oh
yeah that second season it was like the
whole season was like almost coming dude
the first episode I'm like it was it's
like in the Simpsons you know and that
episode where homer strike we so like
the paper trying to roast the pig and
the pig shoots in the sky yeah and Homer
going like it's so good it's so good
yeah what what's your on yeah I'm saying
what you're saying sorry yeah have you
seen any but Sean no I watched the first
episode that was it and that was the
booth added add the best episode of the
season well because yeah because you
didn't need answers in the first episode
you were just being introduced to the
characters right and then you just kept
being reintroduced to the characters
nothing [ __ ] happened yeah thankfully
my theory in this is I think it's
actually good that it was bad cuz
there's no way they would have lived up
to the hype anyway so why not just go
down and [ __ ] well you know the rumor
right because of the director left well
the first season also there
is all that sniffing around about
plagiarism and then this dude scripts
were lifted from somebody else it's just
why the words and the speeches and
everything was so much more concise it
was still a little vague in the first
season but it had a little bite to it in
the second race how long yes in the
second season there's no sniff about
plagiarism he clearly wrote it all
himself but there was just some really
terrible odd like yeah well now we're
gonna be a scrape job yeah I was like oh
really really corny [ __ ] during the last
episode one of the guys actually says I
am the bullet and the blade it is so
rough uh because I think that's a wesley
snipes line yeah I was it was it felt
like it was written by a high school
right and lost his virginity yet yes
spend all day watching quitting
Tarantino movies yeah yes well they try
tried to hard part of the riesling way
to ours like a cut it was like somebody
trying to be Tarantino and David Lynch
yeah same time it was really bad I mean
I wouldn't see it if I were you sure Tom
did you watch all of it it's not even
it's not even worth watching no no it's
really bad it's it's aight it's
frustrating bad its it is it is like
crate like they could do and how did
this get made on it but uh it's it's so
when you what I love that show the first
season maybe as much as I've loved
anything today me too and enough to
watch that fall was crazy but I'm
telling you that that the rumors that
the writing was played a little bit
player as that first season ah just said
i will tell you colin farrell was
[ __ ] great he's always great that guy
he's never he's just picked the world
i'll give you seen him bruges obviously
yeah oh my God he's great oh my god he
just picks the wrong [ __ ] horse every
time that well this you would have
thought going in yeah they were like
with that first season was so good and
did so much for McConaughey and Woody
Harrelson that I'm a [ __ ] yeah I'm
signing and all those care all four
actors have the ability to be really
good yeah you know I liked Rachel
McAdams I don't know man I will usually
like girls are not being said you did
not say before but Vince Vaughn has
never been good in anything dramatic
ever let you name one thing Vince
Vaughn's we're gonna I mean I can't
disprove you
one into the wild was he gonna do the
one-hour drama after psycho do now I
mean come on the lost world guys I don't
know how many psycho was I haven't seen
so I couldn't see just like I couldn't
see psycho psycho is such a perfect
movie yeah I was like why would they
remake that did you see vacation this
one no I did the same thing I didn't
want to hurt it was funny really cuz
they didn't remake it I loved I mean I
love you know I love at Helm's I love I
thought [ __ ] we're the millers was
funny me too you know honey was Miller
we're the millers was funny but I think
it's really look yeah it's really hard
to market an r-rated movie yeah because
you're funny the reason it's our is
because your funniest stuff is the dirty
stuff yeah but you can't show on TV yeah
so every r-rated movie when you look at
it you're like on that looks like a
[ __ ] another soft comedy yeah you get
in there and you're like all that
actually this is funny and listen I know
I'm gonna have I'm gonna be the only
person who says this ever ever and maybe
I was high when i watched it right but
that's my boy with andy samberg and i
have never seen it okay now this i
watched it i watch the ads I'm like
that's gonna be the worst thing I've
ever seen in my life and so but then I
was high on a plane I'm like let's watch
that's my boy and beam and maybe it's
because I think part of it was comedies
is when you go up with high expectations
it never gets met but when you go in
with well there's nothing else on and
you laugh out loud seven times you're
like well that was a success so its
course you don't have in comedy in
general I mean I should just watched wet
ha which is great that [ __ ] the new
season we're not awesome really like
they just they did it they did it it's
great did you see if I it's good it's
good trigger yeah I think there's a
thing that that maybe sometimes comedy
should not be reviewed man I agree it's
you can't trust it you can't trust
comedy reviews subjective who are you to
tell you what they think is funny some
people think the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] is
funny some people think like our own two
and a half men is funny I'm sorry but
that's why that's why you like it
bothers me a little bit as a comic when
I hear comics badmouth other comics
because
for this reason your job as a comic is
to entertain the people who are sitting
in front of you now as long as you're
not stealing other people's material
however you do that is not [ __ ] up to
me to decide I will never do it publicly
I always said that I'll never [ __ ] I got
a Twitter I think I've shed on one
comedy and like I've literally like
years writer like you my uh 10,000
followers guys haha when people call
some here highbrow or low brow or they
call some smart or dumb look we all
think Jon Stewart is smart a smart comic
writer but you watch daily show there's
dick jokes and fart jokes all over that
yeah that's that's the even BBC games
the top of the game yes cousin and the
deal is is like I don't think there
should be highbrow lowbrow smart dumb
comedy yeah if it makes you laugh it
jumps into the comedy pole that's it
look I carrot top I don't know if any of
you have seen him live before you
[ __ ] bad mouthin go to that show go
to that show man and don't go to the
show I just really a documentary on that
guy just cuz the castle he lives a ninja
dude his live show take all your
pretensions away sit down and be like he
went to toys r us grab the trunk full of
toys and he made it his work
entertaining a theater full of people
every [ __ ] night and crushing you try
to do that making millions millions you
know the one thing I've started to
changes i appreciate magicians morning
why don't ever I'm psychometricians dude
yeah I'm starting to I'm started
although I had and you know god bless
this dude I did a show late Friday night
Sean I sent you pictures from it have
you been in the clan room in LA a clown
room it is exactly what you think it is
it is just vintage clown métier like
clown memorabilia in there and they run
shows and there is that it is downtown
LA and the creepiest like true detective
type street and it's just that and it's
the only thing lit at that time of night
so you drive by and it's just clown
faces [ __ ] yet I did a show and it was I
mean it was like it was like the scene
in Texas Chainsaw Massacre where the
girl wakes up at the table haha that's
what it felt like my pull something out
of your beard uh
yeah uh that scene is the most
terrifying scene I think movie history
by the way but are you a horror film Oh
huge horror film guy when he's like when
they're trying to like bend her over and
hit her with a hammer and Ike he's to
like like de fete like the guys too old
to do it out so creepy is that your
favorite horror film no I don't think so
I don't know I mean I it's hard for me
to go past you know the exorcism
Halloween are like so on the same point
yeah I don't know are you Sean are you a
horror film guy no i'm not a big hard
fungi Tom are you yeah I used to have a
thing goriya magazine subscription back
in the day Oh 10 what Thank You Laurie
amazing eyes you said who like who
designed like the models of monsters I
used to do that what do you mean yeah
like you would buy like the MGM like
mummy and then you would get airplane
glue and put him together I didn't talk
to a lot of girls do that when you were
so that was right in between getting
jumping in that [ __ ] right oh my god
you have no idea you know that your
models were bought with 30 Cosby money
yeah dirty good hush money um what's the
what you ever [ __ ] it in have a girl
cheat on me Josh oh yes the most
dysfunctional relationship you ever
ridden I was like the dot white wide
what you're like why did I get in this
this is the dumbest [ __ ] thing ever
Wow probably my the mother of my kids
yeah yeah I mean look you know by the
end of that relationship I walk to
eschew you know we've lived here in
Hollywood and I we I just didn't care I
knew she was out doing whatever and
wherever but I my deal was look you
gotta be home by eight o'clock and you
guys were still together yeah we were
living together so I can go [ __ ] do
my sets you know yeah so she would go
out early in party and so I was like
look I told my brother you watch the
kids for a couple minutes I got to go
get her I go to the bar where I knew she
was yeah I go to the doorman I go hey
man and I don't have any cover money at
the time I can't pay any cover but I I'm
just I know she's in here can I run in
and grab her and run out he goes who are
you looking for and i'll help you out I
know everybody in there cuz it was early
yeah I go I'm looking for a girl named
Malia he goes good choice dude she sucks
a great dick Oh
my god holy shir and I was like I know
and so when you didn't and you didn't
care about I even joked about it with
her on the ride home I go listen I go
ahead lo she sucked the [ __ ] door man
sigh I'm not just a doorman I'm sure I
go I go this and uh II doorman says uh
you suck good dick and she was serious i
tried to play it off she's like uh oh my
god did that didn't rush you hey ah no
at the time get I mean listen honestly
at the time I had just mentally checked
out completely checked out it was just a
situation was probably relieved for you
because then you could just haven't
given you so much more reason to go get
the [ __ ] out no I already knew I knew
what was happening before wasn't like a
huge secret in my brain I was just
trying to figure out how are you jealous
got your now uh I have been I have you
know when I was in college the one girl
I would say that really dropped my
spirits and wrecked my heart yeah I was
jealous with that but you know I came to
a point in my brain where I was like I
can't control anybody else's actions
somebody else is gonna cheat on me or
they're gonna do this I can't control
that all I can do is be me and then if
they're gonna they're so I kinda then
you get her relatives and your elves
together and you stoner yeah exactly
that's how we do it and then and then we
yeah we stoner and we bury her in the
backyard and we got ants coming Jill
pick at her head yes I can't believe too
that that is the core that is the
craziest story I think I've ever heard
yet no there I could with her I could
give you about a hundred stories over
time yeah that really yeah have you ever
walked on a mirror did he ever walk in
on her now here's okay if one of my
favorite I used to talk about this on
stage but yeah she used to tell people i
said i would say i have a girlfriend
well she says fiance I say girlfriend
which was true because she had a ring
but I didn't buy it she bought her own
right and told people we were engaged my
brother was like she's gonna kill you
she's gonna kill you and bury you in the
backyard she was bananas no but the sex
was great she's super funny do you know
what I mean yeah so who cares
yeah but then at some point but now you
would freak out if your wife hook up
with some of the else I think I would
you think that would probably all of me
a little bit yeah that would be tough
one yeah I probably wouldn't be Joe did
you want to tell me something uh yeah me
and I'm trying to get back the in
fortune Fame sure perfect yeah that's
gonna look like yeah we do it oh she's
better looking than me huh ah let me
just say by the way and I want to say
this before I know you do see well let
me just say I'm here in a second um I
don't know if anybody let's just cut you
on my show but you were good every
[ __ ] time thank you every time fun
area I would want to do it again I don't
know what the story hey what's that good
sean's of noise cuz he's not gonna lose
almost [ __ ] ego here's the thing is
like tell me he will be driving about
really good i shall thank you josh it
was really fun it was a really fun show
um Sean cannot handle not being the most
like person in the room and I'm okay
with that i realize i know that but even
on the okay I'm this on the air what
like I'm okay with that because I know
sean is more like than me by most the
how many people i'm not talking about as
an artist who knows there's an art ism
but like I'm just saying like as like a
friend he's more like so whenever
there's a situation where there's
somebody who likes me more than him II
can't [ __ ] take it how well I don't
know I know what and you will and I
don't know you've made maybe but I'm
just saying like he can't do ya gotta be
the guy in the room of like Oh Sean he's
got to do it or else he's like he gets
really annoyed and he's laughing it off
right now but you can tell you can tell
that's one of those last three is like
yeah I would just say I wanted you to
know thank you did eat and the band and
Josh rider episode of that wine people
can check out yeah they're all on CMT
doc on our own team to the object that
show it's Christmas Sean earmuffs you
don't want to hear this I will tell you
this a production company the network
both loves you well thank you so I
appreciate it good [ __ ] man uh thank you
I appreciate it and I'll be I'll be
hosting a new show with the girls from
heart so as I follow combo of the weak
weak joke from the early 90's uh
everything you want to pop free loop uh
just at Josh wolf comedy on Instagram
and Twitter that's this is this is this
week I'm gonna be in go bananas all
weekend
with evan williams has been on the show
super funny guys to check us out there
and Oh ever gonna say this i will be
selling first time with this on the
podcast before this whole Cogan thing
happened yeah I had ordered a bunch of
shirts called st. Romaniacs in st.
Romania and just as I paid for the order
the n-word thing came out with Hogan I
think it's better for you you think
it'll hurry up we'll see what happens
yep John are worried where you this
weekend as I'm a city steam and hartford
connecticut for friday and saturday for
free show city steam hard and it's not
sound like a comedy club i'd say i think
it's a it is a comedy club think county
club restaurant i suppose be pretty good
sounds like a blues venue for like rich
white people city steam yeah yeah good
one that was good I'll just make an
observation not only mentally [ __ ]
zingers Sean well you're the mom yeah
they do okay and I just gave up on now
giving me [ __ ] on that next we gonna be
a crackers and Indianapolis bracket all
right uh Tom yeah i'll be at high plains
Comedy Festival next week and Tom I am
coaching a little league tournament this
weekend ladies and gentlemen dude if
kids there one time we don't have just
an utterly psychologically breaking
moment with you was that for the
pedophiles Alyssa well you I could
describe your vocal tone I'd say
quivering yeah it was not great there's
somebody I forgot to tell you this time
somebody messaged me this week and told
me to take it easy on you and that this
is funny cuz then I message back I'm
like okay i will and then and then the
guy goes but not too easy so I don't
know what that means it means you stay
want to hear him on the brink of you
it's not a highly crowd totally crowd
yeah I'm all I'm right there I'm always
right there alright well thanks guys and
tune in next week bye
thanks guys thanks guys
thanks for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast help keep our podcast
going give us a donation it's been a
little while since we've received any go
to my dumb friends podcast tumblr.com
and you'll find our safe and secure pay
cow paykel paypal link is there send us
a note at my dumb friends podcast at
gmail com we'd love to hear from you we
need to get some emails for our upcoming
mailbag episode so have them start
coming in thanks for listening
the my dumb friends podcasts is part of
the all things comedy network for other
cool comedy podcasts go to all things
comedy calm
daddy came home from the bus our opening
and closing song is called Mary the
boxer by Phil Pickens you can find out
more about Phil Phil Pickens com
you
it was the greatest fight since Frazier
and Ali and they were dancing
slow-motion it was a beautiful commotion
they were hidden like hammers trap
medic City
are you all right throw in the towel you
made us real proud tonight just said no
farther I know when I've been beat and I
still have another round left in me so
lift me up
lift me up lift me up lift me up you
don't know me I've been
you can't me